hi hello and welcome my name is C stosa
I'm working with new Focus uh I'm a
project the Dei coordinator and
basically I will be uh helping to guide
you today uh through uh this impact
scholarship program so uh we have this
opening session right now going just uh
just started uh I hope to share with you
some some information which I hope that
will be helpful for for you for the for
the program as well as we will have some
time for Q&A so still people are uh
still people are coming so let's give
them a little bit of a a time uh I
really hope that you will uh you will
join us for networking session which
will be later today and um we also have
two two very exciting talks about open
source projects um like one in one hour
and then then one later just before
networking
session yeah great having you here and
um excited to start the start the
program great so once again U great
having you here uh and please be welcome
on impact scholarship program um byy
data Global which we are starting just
right now and um the the program is uh
hosted uh during uh during four next day
so we are starting today and uh the the
final day is on Saturday we are
worldwide so basically uh you can meet
people from all over the world people
who are excited about data science
people who are excited about open source
and and all this program is about
knowledge it's about the network and
it's about the inspiration so those are
three uh three very important things
which I really hope that you will uh you
will experience yourself and you will
get gain know new knowledge you will
have a networking options and and
opportunities and you get inspired by
this program so uh so I I really hope
that uh you you can um you can
experience that from the mentors you can
experience that from the speakers at
training training like trainers as well
but also you can you can experience it
from one another so uh I hope that you
will have this amazing amazing
inspiration here and uh the whole
program is about data science and
AI uh it's also about open source so uh
it's like we are combining this this two
words I see there is some
question okay that's the our AI
assistant so we have we have we are
speak speaking about Ai and AI is
helping us uh as well so this session is
recorded as as as you can see uh so
basically it's the program is about data
science it's about AI it's about open
source uh so you can experience uh
knowledge inspiration from from this uh
from this
angles and um the whole program is about
you so we prepare it uh together with uh
with program committee uh to help you to
uh get a better knowledge uh about AI
about data science also on how to make
your first steps or more advanced steps
as well in open source um so it's about
your career it's about your uh your your
choices in career it's about uh
contribution to open source so um it's
about you basically I really hope that
uh this program will be something which
which can help you uh in your uh career
or in your contribution to open
source and as all the events which are
hosted uh by new Focus um this event is
also it's also with the code of conduct
the code of contact of of no Focus which
you can say see on this website you can
find on this website uh and uh the code
code of contact covers all talks or
workshops and um all mentoring session
and also anything which is uh under this
slack for the for the event if anything
will happen which which you feel not
comfortable with and you are suspect
that might be a valuation of code of
conduct please don't hesitate to send us
send us information on this uh email
address contact at no focus.org or you
also can feel uh F the form on this um
on this link on p.org uh Das code of
contuct so uh you have information about
that in your email you also have
information on the website and uh yeah
we definitely want want you to feel
comfortable you we want um any everyone
uh to be to be kind and uh and great to
to each other during the during the
event uh in terms of the agenda
uh so yeah in terms of sorry in terms of
go uh yeah I I really appreciate just uh
uh just being kind kind one to one to
another uh and uh getting into into the
details of the event you have uh you
have the agenda for the event which I
shared with you on uh on email you also
have this information uh plugged on the
uh on the slack and you also have this
information the Google Doc with the main
information for participants so
basically in all this uh fre places you
should be able to see the agenda also
you have uh invitation for some not uh
not all but for at this point for some
talks and sessions in your email like a
invitation for the for the event and uh
basically uh basically you should be
able to find this agenda if you for some
reason have an um problem to find the
the agenda please send me send me
information on slack or just ask on the
general channel uh but uh but this
information is pinked to the general
Channel like this General Event Channel
um this by data uh impact all uh Channel
as well so basically uh basically uh
today we have today we have two talks
and two sessions
and on Thursday on Thursday we'll be
hosting uh hosting of workshops and and
session as well a Friday those are two
um two session and most of the most of
the uh things will be happening during
uh Saturday Saturday is the the biggest
uh day for for us also Saturday is the
only day which is not uh overlapping
with P data Global main event so you
will be uh you will be able to attend
only in uh in this uh impact scholarship
program uh if you uh if you wish uh wish
for and uh I totally encourage you to uh
take this opportunity to attend in
networking session which will be today 8
800 PM UTC zero and also bir of feather
uh it's um it's amazing opportunity for
you to uh to talk I see see that there
is a hand uh
Yes actually I got confused about birds
of a feather this session is regarding
what because networking I got to know
like this
networking like the Saturday session is
regarding what I mean birth of feather
yes so uh birs of feather it's a it's
type of event which is used in open-
Source communities all over the world
and that this type of the event it's
about
uh it's um basically on the beginning of
the session we will decide as a group uh
so basically uh you will decide and uh
and I will just uh moderate it what kind
of topics do you want to speak about and
then when you when you when we together
decide about the topics and then uh we
uh create breakout breakout rooms and
you will be able to discuss these topics
uh in this break room so sometimes in
birds of feather you can uh you can
submit topics before uh in this uh this
one you please um have your topic which
you would like to discuss um yeah before
the event but but basically now you will
be submitting that during the event and
then I I will uh create this breakout
rooms and you will be able to discuss
what kind of topics do uh can you
discuss oh basically um those are topics
connected with AI open source also
connected with uh with with data science
your career and anything which actually
anything which is uh okay with code of
of conduct you can you can discuss if uh
we will have a fans of Star Wars let's
say or Star Trek um and you would like
to discuss that that's also okay so
basically it depends on the group it's
very open format it's something similar
to uh to conference um but in a smaller
smaller um scale because it's only two
hours H does it answer your
question
yes okay perfect thank thank you for the
question yes uh please ask um definitely
uh please raise your hand I see
something on the
chat uh yeah it's informal um Kalan
exactly it's uh inform
um version of panel
discussion and definitely definitely
true and yeah so you will have this two
uh two different options uh for uh
basically for discussion for knowing one
another um which I really hope that you
will take advantage uh
from and mentoring session something
which I know that many many of you are
looking for uh we uh at at this point we
definitely can secure a 30 minutes of
mentoring session for each of you if
we'll have more slots uh then uh I will
make sure that uh that you will know
that and basically um basically um yeah
I will announce that you can use more
than one mentoring session uh so you
will get this information on slack and
via email but at this point please um if
you didn't secure your uh your uh
session yet please do that and there is
this procedure how to do that uh and uh
basically first of all you are going to
this document when you are uh choosing
your mentor and the mentoring session
time still uh some sometimes are not uh
not listed there for some mentors um
sorry for that uh it's just Bas
basically some mentors didn't uh do that
yet they are very very busy it's it's
something which uh uh which really hope
that will be um done soon and basically
first of all you are in the spreadsheet
you are securing your um your your
session and then uh when the time of the
your session is um is there you um make
sure that you are already registered for
pi data Global air mid space uh the
space is open now it was open today um
3:00 a.m.
um P Pacific Standard time uh so it's
definitely open now and will be open uh
till the till the end of
Saturday and uh and uh in there uh when
you will register and you can uh and
enter the lunch in the lunch you can
find the table with the name of your uh
of your me mentor and at the time of
your session you are basically um
approaching you entering this byata
Global airit um airit platform and you
are uh you are going to launch there is
this picture of where the lunch uh lunch
is and then you will see uh the tables
with with
mentors
um where you can use add uh where where
can you when where could we access the
spreadsheet yes that's an excellent
question so basically the same as with
agenda you have this information on your
email you have this information on the
slack uh on the Spy data impact 2023 all
uh slack Channel and you also have this
information in Google doc P data impact
uh 2023 information for participants so
basically please uh please please take a
look at your email box uh definitely you
will have an email uh from me with uh
with this with this document also um if
that will be more handy please uh go to
this SL SL Channel and this instruction
together with the agenda is just pin for
the channel so uh so basically uh that
should be hopefully an easy access to
you
um do will will you get the confirmation
for the uh for the session like uh
I now actually you will not get the
confirmation of the session um we really
um believe in like U that that we are
like a responsible people here so
basically the mentor should be um like
the only information which uh which you
will you will get will be in the
stretches so when you will T type your
um well when you will type your um name
uh securing the the slot and that's the
only information which uh which you will
provide and that's only information for
the mentor um please do not remove
others uh people's slots and now you
will not get uh unfortunately you will
not get any any confirmation of that you
Al always can uh can try to reach your
uh your mentor to to True slack so
that's why we have this slack Channel
you also can uh send them a direct
message
okay so uh this mentoring uh sessions um
I will be on the slack as well if you
still will have some uh some issue with
mentoring sessions uh please send me a
direct message and we will proceed from
there uh yeah slack slack channel uh
basically this uh this by data impact
2023 all slack channel uh is the place
for you uh to get to know other par
participants to get to know mentors so
please feel free and that's totally okay
with the program if you will share your
LinkedIn if you share your GitHub if you
share information about the projects
which you are doing um please do not
share any like advertisement for uh for
um maybe not job offers uh especially if
you have some job offer which you would
like to share please send that to me and
uh and uh uh we if we'll have more this
job offer we can definitely uh we can
definitely send some uh General um
communication around that uh but um but
if you have something which your is
yours your project open source project
your project which is not open source
but you are very proud of uh please
share that on the channel it's something
for you to get to know other participant
mentors and basically um to also discuss
discuss things connected with data
science Ai and open source uh but also
discuss fun stuff if you would like to
discuss something about your uh about
anything which you are really uh like um
really into if you have some hobby which
you would like to share as long as it's
okay with code of conduct um that's
that's perfectly fine that's something
which also can help you to meet other
people and can help with the
communication so please please please
use uh slack
Channel networking session uh we'll have
this networking session today uh 800 PM
UTC Z and during the networking session
uh we'll have one hour um basically to
to get to know each other and uh I will
ask you two questions um that's uh
that's something which you I'm giving
you hands hands up about that I will ask
you about um your story with data
science a and your story with open
source and uh during the networking
session um yeah we we will have uh first
of all we'll have time together in the
in in the uh room and then uh basically
for this discussion and then basically
um after uh after some some short
discussion I will prepare uh breakout
rooms and uh yeah and in this scenario
you will be able to like Join one
breakout room then you can just jump
into another and uh hopefully you will
be able to speak with uh with uh with
more more people and during this
networking session um the reason for the
breakout rooms is like um um I want you
to have a time basically to to speak
with one another and uh usually this
kind conversation are okay with a groups
of five up to seven people so uh I
definitely would like to make you this
opportunity and also um one thing which
is not listed here uh but that's um
that's that's something which might be
really handy for you uh besides the
mentoring sessions uh when you will um
enter the air me P data Global a meid
this one which is all in all the
communication uh you also can schedule
one to one meetings with with people so
uh it's not listed there that's just the
and that's uh just um possibility which
herit has and um and basically you
definitely can can do that feel free to
do that it's something different than
mentoring session but it's also an
option uh for you which you can add
unlock by um by entering the P data
Global
hermit
okay so uh that's all from uh my side uh
it's 8 uh 20 a.m. in San
Francisco uh we still have a lot of time
uh so that's time for you for uh for
questions and I hope that I will be able
to
answer thanks dear uh may I ask you a
question please uh thank you very much
for your
presentation of course yes
please so uh dear Camila I would like to
ask you this question when we want to uh
start the mentoring session with our
Mentor we just enter airit the launch
section and uh open the U and join the
room of our
Mentor
exactly okay thank you very much of and
regarding to the
workshops uh as I'm aware tutorials and
workshops are totally
different and uh during the
workshops um can we um also require any
um recordings regarding the workshops
afterwards if we didn't manage to join
can we uh have a
recording uh yes thank you for this
question and definitely recordings all
of all talks and workshops will be
available there might be situation like
last Min a situation when um um Mentor
or uh or trainer uh would not um agree
for the uh for for recording that might
happen it's very
unlikely uh so in any other situation
you will have this recording um
available after the event so uh yes with
with impact scholarship program you will
have this available um hopefully next
week but I could not promise that in
this point um in terms of by data Global
which I hope that you also um take part
in which is very great event um you will
have access to the recording just after
the record that um was taken so you can
basically tap on the recording just
after the session uh so but but
basically yes you will have an access to
to recording for both um workshops and
and uh for uh for talks as well thank
you very much for your author answer
thank you very
much thank you Ari thank you for the
question okay we have something on the
chat
um yes exactly you can reach the mentor
you will not get a confirmation for your
mentoring session but you can reach the
mentor that's definitely
true
um can you share the spreadsheet here uh
yes we definitely can do
that uh the spreadsheet for mentoring
session I
believe
um okay
so the mentoring
session so I just as you can see I just
showed
the um spreadsheet for the mentoring
session yes please use only uh spaces
which are uh which are marked by your
your name and surname uh which are empty
basically so where there is no someone
else uh name and
surname I'm still confused with one
question here so just want to understand
let's say if one of the m has blocked
interested in taking a mentorship with
me so I think they puted their name in
the time slot whatever the time slot
which I given right so after that how do
I get the notification so will it be
someone who will be sending an email
notification or someone from send it or
how does it work this is something I'm
confused uh so I'm not sure if I get
your question right but I will try to
answer so basically when uh someone will
type the name and uh surname in in your
slot uh then uh then that information
will be in the
uh in the spreadsheet and that's the
only information which we are getting so
you are not getting any email you are
not getting any calendar
invitation sorry the the only
information is in the spreadsheet so
just please um take a look at the
spreadsheet we don't have that
automatized any anyhow uh if that was
your question or uh did I misunderstood
that okay so once the D are in the
spreadsheet so I'll be looking into the
spreadsheet but how this this meeting
mentoring happen so the m has was
supposed to sched a meeting
with the scheduling me meeting is just
by typing the M name and surname next to
the uh like next to the column of the of
the person maybe I will share
this uh on the screen right
now that will be
easier
okay so you should see my screen with
the
spreadsheet and great so for example in
here uh we have
Andrea
Leah Le and basically uh there is some
individual who uh who secured the um
mentoring session book the moning
session for December 9th 11: a.m. um 8 8
uh yeah uh in this time zone so
basically that's the information that at
this time on December 9th 11 a.m. UTC 8
uh this individual and Andrea should
meet in the in the a meit um on P data
Global uh Lounge um um next to the table
with with the name Andrea
Leah all right got
it okay perfect thank you uh if still
something will be not clear uh you
always can can send me um direct message
and I will be uh happy to
answer
okay
okay uh is there anything
else which
um yeah is there anything else which you
would like to ask discuss or maybe share
with uh with other participants other
like mentors and and me as
well
if uh you will not have any uh any other
questions oh thank thank you Jonathan uh
if you will not have uh any any other
questions um definitely please please
remember about this networking session
which we are having today uh please be
active on slack um we have wonderful
four days uh ahead of us I really hope
that you will enjoy talks workshops and
uh you will meet great people and you
can learn uh things which will be
helpful uh for you for your career for
for your um also for your
um basically contribution to open source
and uh yeah and if you'll have any um
if you any if you will have any question
please um um send me a slack message or
you also can SL send me an email you
definitely have my email and I'm just
seeing what's going on the
chat um thank you Cam actually I I have
a question about like
so as a
speaker I saw there's Zoom link so we
are not doing air meet right for the P
global impact yes that's correct so uh
basically for from some logistic reasons
uh for speakers for for sorry for talks
and for the workshops we are doing Zoom
so it will be the same uh setup uh as uh
as we have right now we are doing Zoom
you can enter the room 15 minutes before
uh each session um yeah uh M I'm very
excited about about your contribution
and uh yeah um basically uh we you will
provide that on the zoom okay so like
like it's going to be 15 minutes before
I'm going to just join the zoom and
that's it yeah and that's it uh that's
uh is it isest possible scenario um yeah
like 15 minutes before we'll check uh we
will check your sharing your screen uh
we'll check the audio things like that
uh also um this time uh other like
participants also can be in the room uh
there is no like uh there is no green
room there is no like preparation room
it's uh it will be open um but we'll be
able to check the most uh the most
crucial
things sounds great perfect looking
forward uh there is also a question
about the slack uh slack link um I will
generate that right now because
the um yeah just to make it
easier okay so uh you should have an
access uh to slack uh via email uh you
should have
the
um invitation in the
email uh there was
[Music]
um yeah have you thank you Jonathan see
see you later
um so uh I just sent you the U the link
for the slack channel uh there is a
question for um part uh do mentors needs
to register to have tickets so uh
basically U basically please uh for your
mentoring session please register on AIT
and uh the same as mentors are reg
registrating the same way as mentees and
basically this uh registration which is
which the information have to register
with with the procedure is uh is listed
in this uh document which is pinned to
the uh to the channel and also which I
sent sent you via email uh you can you
can register uh for the
uh air meet P dat Global a meit and that
will give you an access to the launch
and uh in the Louch there is a table
with your name and surname and that's uh
that's the way how you access that so do
you need to have a a ticket uh yes you
have a special like you and all mentors
and all participants have a special type
of tickets uh you don't need to uh go
through like a regular one um the the
link to the registration is in the
document which is also the same document
which uh you have here in this
conversation which I sent um sent here
as a mentoring session registration
that's also this document will uh guide
you also uh how to how to register uh
for for the
platform uh does it answer your
question
uh no sorry I'm just I I cannot find
that information there's just too many
links to too many documents but none of
them mention
Amit uh and I'm really struggling to
find the right uh
pin okay so I will share my screen and
I
um okay so you should see my screen the
because there is this bi dat
impact uh there is one
pin and there is
this oh mentoring session
registration oh and you can go
here that's basically this uh link for
the
registration and there is this uh the
sticket which will help you to get into
the
um yeah into the launch of our
so you can find that
uh you can find that on the Spy data
impact 2023 all
channel it's pinned
here and there is this uh Point number
three which is registration
and basically I will
resend I will resend this
document of this one I will res send
this document
um once again on the yeah on the chat
here
can you make it the anyone with the link
will be commenter because we don't want
to we don't want to see any changes on
this document
right that would be better yes that's
that's very
[Music]
true okay I will I will do that right
after okay so um yeah that's that's very
very true I I will do that after
um
so um B um does it help like could could
you find the registration link right
now
um
yeah sorry the uh I was fighting with
slack uh trying to get access to the um
the list of
channels
uh yeah no I I got it okay yeah so the
definitely the easiest way is is like
you have the link in the chat right now
here in this Zoom call and uh then you
have the point number three which is
registration okay uh any other questions
and other uh issues um any problems with
slack uh which we have seen before as
well but but we definitely can manage
that next year I really hope that we we
will use um different uh different
platform sorry for all this um uh issues
with with this
lag yeah
thank you
Ariel um
okay you know where where to find
me and I really hope that you will have
a great time uh are are there any other
questions or comments or something which
you would like to
share
exactly don't forget to have fun uh
definitely I hope that you will uh have
some some some fun with uh with um yeah
enjoying uh enjoying the the sessions
enjoying the talks enjoying the
workshops uh yeah